today we're gonna eat some bugs crap
online I'll bring it on
I've never intentionally eating a bug I
was stung in the mouth once by be my
first thoughts on this is there's gross
looks like a Cronenberg no looks like a
like a small dinosaur tail you see this
one we got mummified like you oh yeah
like the eyes they kind of smell like um
the kind of smoked raisins like prunes
get crunchy good usually not bad taste
like what potpourri smells like not bad
is not good what smells good it looks
like the character in men in black Hey
uh-huh I can't believe our football that
one has a little squirm to it it just
tastes like a vegetable is it's kind of
like crunchy Frazier is the leg pull up
around
I got fuel I got bit on it's like but
and it just kind of like take that look
like a look like a waffle it's like a
fancy dinner Beverly Hills Oh mmm Oh
body fell off oh I ate half a scorpion
just put them on top of something else
and then they're totally fine I'm not
badass cuz I eat a scourge me that's
true
let this finger it well no I think it's
up I ain't no whole thing I'm kind of
into this it's pretty good scorpion on
shrimp essence winter doesn't bug me Oh
boom squishy bug explode in my mouth
it's like oysters when they pop and like
uh I wouldn't go out of my way to eat it
again we're countries got to eat these
things sooner or later anyway I will get
used to it now mass hoppers were late
those are mad hell
right like that's something you can just
snack on like forever
drunken hungry uncle work this would be
great with all this stuff
yeah just put a bunch of cheese on top
of it I would eat mm-hmm all this with
cheese oh yeah